hello today I'm gonna show you how to
program a key fob to a Ford vehicle goes
from 19 I think
1990 we're gonna say 7 and onwards right
now I'm in my dad's 2012 Ford f-150 now
of course you stole it on this video
because you can't program your key phone
well that's what I'm here for
and so now there's two styles of keys
with button so you got this one that
came originally what the truck and he
got this fob this will work are there a
program to say it doesn't matter if you
have this key fob style this key fob
style they work to say so what you're
gonna do is you're gonna take your key
I'm gonna insert it into the ignition
and you're gonna cycle it on before you
write before you start it and back off
like that eight times and on the eighth
time you're gonna leave it in E on
position you're gonna leave it the on
position you're gonna hear the lock
cycle when the locks cycle you're gonna
push a button doesn't matter it's a lock
unlock trunk panic doesn't matter when
you do that you're ready here the lock
cycle again
and then you remove the key locks of
cycle one more time ending the program
and you're good so we'll do that gonna
walk cycle take a key fob hit the button
lock suckled walk cycle again and now
you're good now because this my this is
a truck and doesn't have a trunk the
trunk button does not work but this fob
will work so let's say you have this fob
and the Keyblade broke and let's just
say getting one of these is more
expensive than just up this fob
well actually that wouldn't work either
wouldn't nevermind okay since ignore
what I was going to say they're gonna
say you can just get one of these and
program it but if the blade is broken
then yeah so anyway oh well I guess what
you can't do is if this fob is bad
completely buddy tried to change
batteries try programming it nothing
happens and it ends up being more
expensive to get one of these and these
just by one of these program it and just
keep it on the keyring use this to lock
and unlock the car but have this to put
in ignition and start it so and of
course these keys don't go to this truck
it's not before this truck that's what
this is for
that goes to the truck and just to show
you that thing still works at this shut
so anyway that is how you program a key
fob for a Ford vehicle now this works
was Ford Lincoln Mercury Mazda of this
airs for like the Mazda Tribute which is
a Ford Escape the Mercury Mariner Ford
Explorer
no that's the Mercury Mariner is the
xscape Mercury I forget what the mercury
version of the Explorer is but then you
got the markers sable for Taurus things
like that so I'll show you gotta do it
one more time Vincent the key and eight
times one two three four five six seven
eight
in a fob and there you go that's how you
program a key fob for Ford Lincoln
Mercury I'm not sure how far back older
Ford's work for different fob like a 93
Explorer
I don't think 93 X force at it I think
but like a 94 95 I don't know if third
it's the same process if they are or you
can try it if not you'll have to look up
on the Internet the technique on how to
program it for that so anyway I hope
this helped like leave a like a comment
down below and if you haven't already
please subscribe to the channel
they're little be playing more vehicle
programming Keys wouldn't come available
and other repair videos when I can do
all thanks for watching
I'll talk to you guys later